there's been projects throughout the
internet that have done incredible job
of that but have been also very flawed
like Wikipedia is an example of a big
leap forward in doing that it was pretty
damn impressive what's your overall take
I mean I I'm mostly impressed so there's
a few really
powerful ideas for the people who edit
Wikipedia one of which is each editor
kind of for themselves declares
you know I'm into politics and I really
kind of a left-leaning guy so I really
shouldn't be editing political articles
because I have bias so they're great
they declare their biases and they often
do a good job of actually declaring the
biases but there will still like they'll
find a way to justify themselves like
something will piss them off yeah and
they want to correct it because they
they love correcting untruth into truth
but the perspective of what is true or
not is affected by their bias Ruth is
hard to know and I and and it is true
that there is a left-leaning bias on the
editors of Wikipedia so for that what
happens is on articles which I mostly
appreciate that don't have a political
aspect to them you know
um scientific articles or technical
articles they can be really strong even
history just describing the facts of
history that don't have a subjective
element a strong all also just using my
own brain I can kind of filter out if
it's uh you know if it's something about
January 6 or something like this I know
I'm going to be like I'm not whatever's
going on here I'm gonna kinda read it
but most I'm gonna look to other source
I'm going to look to a bunch of
different perspectives on it it's going
to be very tense there's probably going
to be some kind of bias maybe some
wording will be such which is one where
this is where Wikipedia does its thing
the way they word stuff will be biased
the choice of words but the what
Wikipedia editors themselves are so
self-reflective they literally have
articles describing these very effects
of how you can use words to inject bias
yeah in in all the ways that you talk
about it that's not healthier than most
environments it's incredibly healthy but
I think you could do better one of the
big flaws of Wikipedia to me that
Community notes on X does better is the
accessibility of becoming an editor
um is it's difficult to become an editor
and it's not as visible the process of
editing so I would love like you said a
stream yeah everyone to be able to
observe this debate between people with
Integrity of when they discuss things
like January Stakes a very controversial
topics to just see how the processes the
debate goes as opposed to being hidden
in the shadows which currently is in
Wikipedia you can access that it's just
hard to access but and I've also seen
how they will use certain articles like
on certain people like articles about
people have learned to trust less and
less yeah because they'll literally will
use those to make personal attacks and
this is something you write about
they'll use uh descriptions of different
controversies to paint a picture of a
person that's
that doesn't to me at least feel like an
accurate representation of the person
it's like writing an article about
Einstein mentioning something about uh
theory of relativity and saying that he
was a womanizer and abuser and a like
controversy you know yeah he is Feynman
also you know not you know was that you
know they're not exactly the perfect
human in terms of women but like there's
other aspects to this human and to
capture that human properly there's a
certain way to do it I think Wikipedia
will often lean they really try to be
self-reflective and
try to stop this but they will lean into
the drama if it matches the bias yeah
but again
much better than the world I believe is
much better
uh because Wikipedia exists but
now that we're in these adolescent
stages we're growing and trying to come
up with different Technologies the idea
of a stream yeah is really really
interesting as you get more and more
people into this discourse that where
the value is let's try to get the truth
yeah
yeah and that basically you know you get
full of cards for nope wrong nope wrong
and the different the different
rhetorical techniques that are being
used to avoid actually discussing yeah
and I think I actually can make it a
little bit Fun by you get a limited
number of them
um you know it's kind of like you get
three what about some cards so gamifying
the whole thing uh absolutely